hello everyone I hope you're all having
a wonderful Saturday as here we have a
very nice game from a match that took
place on Father's Day it's Hikaru
Nakamura versus Komodo the Dragon engine
now it's a new engine on chest that
comet has 20 had 20 levels and this is a
game he played against Komodo level 14
now in all of the games Nakamura had the
white pieces but after the game he also
played after the match of 20 games he
played against all 20 levels then he
also played three more games but against
a stronger improved version but we're
gonna visit that after we check out this
game so as a human engine matches today
are very rare so it's very interesting
that and Nakamura agreed to do this and
we're gonna check out his result after
we check out this game so prior to this
game he already defeated the first 13
levels and now he faces level 14
I believe it's rated around 2100
something but if you think that like
playing against that 21 something human
you would be you would be mistaken
because it's always more difficult to
play against an engine but you are also
welcome to challenge level 14 yourselves
and see for yourself so that being said
let's check it out Nakamura has the
white pieces and he opens would be three
the names of each Larsen attack way and
he has the right idea you don't wanna
you don't want to try some aggressive
openings and you know take take the game
immediately into you know a heavy
combination waters so better to go
strategically into this match we have d5
Bishop to b2 Knight f6 III and c5 Knight
to e2 Knight to c6 and now d3 d4 could
have been also played but Hiro Nakamura
plays d3 and he allows this d4 okay we
have efore now this dark square bishop
isn't to doing all that well II five g3
Bishop to e7 Nakamura I think it was the
second Bishop as well and here you could
simply start with castles maybe develop
the bishop or something but here
actually stock
stockfish Komodo goes for a very
interesting point sacrifice here come on
oh please c4 and it's very interesting
that you could you can actually capture
this pawn with either the B pond or the
D pawn but of course it's always you
know it's principle to capture towards
the center and its interests in
interesting white Komodo does this after
B captures and c4 Queen to b6 displayed
so developing the Queen wouldn't attack
on the bishop so still forcing Nakamura
to figure what to do here and still kind
of keeping his King in the center of the
board Bishop to see one getting the
bishop added weight now Bishop to g4 we
have castles castles and now h3 kicking
the bishop back
Bishop to d7 9th to d2 we have a six and
here Nakamura is up upon but his
position is very boxed in so here he
decides to seemingly ruin his position
but not really
he plays f4 we have it captures on f/4g
captures on f4 and now knife to e8
preparing to remain over the night and
also make make room for his bishops and
as you can see the the kingside
structure here of the pawns isn't all
that great but nakamura will use this
very nicely and use the g file to create
a nice attack against the black king
Knight to g3 we have Bishop to h4 came
to h2 now 97 Knight to f3 and now Bishop
captures and g3 King captures and yes
Nakamura's king is on g3 but you know
all is always well here Queen b6 King
goes back to h2 we have f6 and King goes
back all the way to h1 rook to f7 and
now Queen to e1 preparing to bring the
Queen over 2g 396 Queen does come to g3
rook to b8 and King to h2 now here
kimono seemingly doesn't have a plan
probably b5 was the idea here but for
some reason
Komodo now place rook to d8 we have f5
kicking away the night nice to e5 and
now Bishop to f4
Knight captures on f3 would check Bishop
captures and now Queen to b4
bringing the Queen over to the Queen
side and maybe go
after those a weak bones but Nakamura
doesn't really care
he plays Bishop to h5 attacks the rope
here rook to e7 and now rook to f2
preparing to bring this rook over to g2
and also preparing to bring the a1 rook
all the way to g1 so Queen to a3 we have
rope to g1 and now King to f8 you can't
capture the a two point if you capture
the a to pawn then you get Bishop to b6
and this rope doesn't have anywhere to
go and if you capture here then Queen
captures and again there's no way to
save this rook only square available to
this rook is e5 but after this of course
you get Queen captures on f6 and it's
game over
you can't defend both checkmate and
Queen captures on d8 so after rook g1 we
have came to a fate in getting out of
the G file a rook F - G - now with a
nice triple barrier on the G file Bishop
to a4 and now Queen to h4 and here Queen
captures on a2 is played comodo really
underestimated Nakamura's attack here
and capturing upon it's not about
capturing a pawn just there really there
is no better move you can do here if you
play something like rook D to d7 to kind
of maybe defend the position a bit more
then you get this Bishop to g6 idea and
of course now the Queen can easily come
here to check me the black King and of
course if you capture then again Queen
h8 King moves now pawn captures King
escapes and now Queen to g8 rope to f7
and now comes Queen to e8 check and the
King has nowhere to go so you have to
block with the rook once again rook
moves and now Quinta g8 a nice windmill
idea
rook has the block again and now pawn
captures and here but is completely lost
after characters we have captures simply
captures captures captures captures and
the white will be up a whole rook so
after Queen to h4 there is a there's
really no good move here so rook Queen
capture some a2 was played and now
Nakamura has several ways of dealing
with this position you can simply
capture capture the night on e 8 and
then go for rook captures on g7 button a
camera plays a nicer
Bishop to h6 and now there really isn't
anything to do
of course capturing is impossible due to
roof 2g8 checkmate and after what was
played King to g8 and now we have a
bishop captures here and Queen to a3
Queen to a3 is very much necessary but
it doesn't really help in any way after
rook captures Bishop then you get rook
captures and after Luke captures rook
captures of course came to h8 and now
after Queen captures and f6 there is no
defense here Queen captures in situ
check and now rock blocks and by
blocking check also the Queen now
delivers checkmate
so after Bishop captures we have Queen
to a 3 and here nakamura plays Bishop
captures and g7 it's a completely
winning move but it's it's it's a longer
win better yet was rook captures because
now you have rook captures rook captures
here and after King h8 now of course
Queen to f6 will be met with Queen
returning and it will prolong mate for
some time but after Luke g8 check simply
king is forced to capture and now Queen
g4 check King has to move and now Queen
to g7 will be checkmate so yeah after
Queen to a3 Bishop captures and g7 was
played Bishop captures and now Bishop
captures and f6 opening up a discovered
check from the rooks bunch of g6 we have
pawn captures now King moves from the G
file G captures on h7 threatening h8
Queen ro capture screen captures and
here there is really nothing to do
anymore
Queen d6 check a common or at least on
this level it doesn't seem to be able to
resign so here even even the Queen is
given Bishop captures and after King
here nakamura even delivers checkmate to
Komodo
the dragon engine so rope to g8 and this
is checkmate so now a very nice game by
Nakamura against Komodo level 14 and
it's interesting yeah we already said
that he defeated all 13 levels prior to
level 14 and he defeated all levels up
to level 19 and he defeated level 19 and
only he lost one game and that's the
comodo level 20 I was uh if you want I
can also show that game as it
very nice and then after these 20 games
Nakamura faced an even stronger
Komodo engine called Komodo menthe and
Monte Carlo and here I did prepare some
it's from an article by Peter Dodgers
Sanchez calm as you can see in this
three games are always ten minutes plus
five seconds increment Komodo Monte
Carlo was running on a powerful sixteen
core computer I 9 7 9 6 o ex overclocked
to 4.1 gigahertz 64 gigabytes of RAM and
5 piece Zig z endgame tablebases ok and
the key difference is that komodo monte
carlo chooses its moves by wind
probability instead of traditional
evaluation the approach is similar to
the probabilistic methods of the machine
learning chess projects alpha 0 and
Leela chess so very interesting but
against the comodo monte carlo nakamura
did not play regular chess rather of
course the strong engine had to give
Nakamura odds and in all three games the
odds were different and were very
interesting so I'll put I will put a
link to the original article you're very
welcome to check it out and check out
all of the games there especially the
three games against como de monte-carlo
yeah that's that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Thomas Thompson and Oliver purged for a
contribution to my channel and you know
congratulations all over on your three
and a half points out of 15 and you know
playlist poker more chess so yeah as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon with hopefully a nice
video and I almost forgot yeah I did
prepare a photo challenge for this video
so here it is the best of luck to
everyone you all know who it is so I'm
pretty sure you're gonna really nail
this one here it is who is this a very
nice gentleman so yeah that's it I think
all and I will see you soon